- You said you run obstacle
courses, right? Like--
- You should try.
It's a lot of fun.
- I might.
I've got to get through this
marathon in December first.
- Oh, good God.
Oh, that's great, so how do you
like to train for that?
- Four-day-a-week runs and
then--
or base mileage runs--and then
long runs on the weekend.
So how do you train for
obstacle courses?
Do you have one in your
backyard?
- No.
God, I wish I did.
- That would be nice.
- There's a park, actually, a
local park
that is an obstacle course.
- Oh.
- And you can go there
and run the course a time
couple times--
however long--how many times
you want.
- Yeah, so is that how you lost
all your weight
since you got into this, or...
- [indistinct].
I started just walking and
dieting.
And I don't--I wasn't starving
myself.
But I followed a calorie count
until I lost
the first 50 pounds.
- Yeah.
- And then after that
is when I really started
getting into
more exercise again.
- Yeah.
- I've always been active,
but I kind of just let myself
drop off for a long time.
- Yeah.
- But especially when you have
a kids, you know...
- Oh, yeah, absolutely.
Same thing happened to me.
I played sports all my life
growing up,
and then I had my daughter in
'98, and...
- So did I.
- You just--really?
- In '98, yeah.
- You get focused on taking
care of your kid.
Then you forget to take care of
yourself. That's the--
- Well, you always put them
ahead.
- Yeah.
- So how did you--
what did you do to drop the
weight?
- I found the Couch to 5K plan.
- Oh, yeah.
- And when I started, I was
about 198 pounds,
and I thought I was gonna die
just running two minutes.
- Yeah.
- It was terrible.
But within three months had
dropped [indistinct]
and then three months was
running three miles
four to five times a week and
then dropped about 35 pounds.
- Wow.
- Then found out I was pregnant
with my third child.
- Oh, my goodness.
- So are you excited about the
course?
- I'm super excited.
- Are you nervous about
the course?
- I'm very nervous.
- You're very nervous.
- Yeah, I've never done
anything like this before.
- Me neither.
My biggest concern is just
remembering my plan
once I get out there.
- Yeah, yep.
You've got to remember to just
stop for a second...
- Yep.
- And not just run right
through it; try to--
- Square up.
- Yeah.
- And think for just a--just
for a second,
and then go for it.
- It's gonna be hard to do,
though,
'cause you want to rush through
it; you want to get done, but--
- Yeah, well, time, that's
gonna be going through my head
is this, "Let's go. Let's go.
Let's go."
- I'm gonna treat it like a
marathon.
- Yeah.
- I run just to finish.
- I don't run for time.
- I'm not fast, but we'll see
how it goes.
- We'll see.
It's exciting.
And it's really exciting
there's two girls.
- Yes, yes, I was shocked,
because I think there were
only three or four on the first
season.
- It's gonna be fun.
- That's awesome.
- I know.
- I was thinking I'd be
the only girl here.
Girl power.